the Donald Trump rape trial has started
a lot to discuss here as well started
yesterday NPR has a good primer we might
call it five things to know as e Gene
Carroll's Civil Trial begins against
Donald Trump jury selection begins
Tuesday this is the defamation suit
brought against Trump by E.G and Carroll
late last year Carol accused Trump of
causing significant pain and suffering
lasting psychological harms loss of
dignity and invasion of her privacy
Trump's lawyers say the statute under
which the assault claim was brought
against Trump violates due process the
core of this is that Carol claims Trump
raped her in the changing room of the
Bergdorf Goodman Department Store in
Manhattan in the 1990s
the suit says as a result of the pain
and suffering caused by that sexual
assault she has not been able to sustain
a romantic relationship since that day
Trump's lawyers are expected to argue
Carroll's nearly 30-year-old claims
cannot be proved and that she was
motivated by potential Book Sales and
publicity
um important to know Carol has sued
Trump already twice and both matters are
still active there's the defamation suit
from November of 2019
and a November 22 suit filed under New
York's adult survivors act which opens a
one-year window when people allege
sexual assault to bring civil claims
older than those that would normally be
allowable so that is happening there are
not cameras in the courtroom there are
not cameras in the courtroom as far as I
was able to research this morning a
couple other notes the trial and
Manhattan federal court is expected to
last five to seven days reports Business
Insider and uh Donald Trump is not there
in person Trump said in October on Truth
Central this Miss Bergdorf Goodman case
is a complete con job it's a hoax and a
lie like all the other hoaxes that have
been played on me for the last seven
years it is unclear whether Trump will
attend any of the trial in person for
the time being Trump uh has not been
there e Gene Carroll is indeed there the
reason I bring this up is not because
anything in particular has transpired at
the trial yet that is newsworthy or
noteworthy but because I do think it's
important not to forget that this is yet
another legal issue that is facing Trump
that is in the news whose outcome could
could impact Trump's 2024 run we'll
follow it we'll let you know what
happens